as he has fired all of these people at
Twitter a lot of lefties are freaking
out and saying they're going to leave
Twitter they're going to go build things
and blah blah blah they're not going to
build anything because Equity doesn't
lead you to being able to build anything
you're too focused on your engineer's
skin color one of the people that's not
happy about Elon Musk is a-o-c yeah she
wrote on Twitter shout out to all the
workers at Twitter you all built a vital
place for connected and deserved so much
for connection and deserves so much
better millions of people appreciate the
space you built and the hard work that
went into it thank you uh and then Elon
Musk I mean he's getting good at this
you're welcome that's all he wrote
you're welcome now just quickly on the
AOC thing and these people that are
upset by what's happening on Twitter
let's understand this clearly Elon Musk
has not come in and said I'm going to
censor people on the left he has not
said I'm going to trample on anyone's
free speech he has said we are going to
allow more more voices here he has said
we are going to try to respect Free
Speech a little more honestly and we're
gonna we're gonna be a little more
upfront about our policies we're not
going to randomly or not even randomly
because we don't know if it's random or
not we are not going to use the levers
of power as our employees see fit to
decide who the winners or losers are who
you can see and who you can't see and
everything else now who's that upsetting
to isn't this so interesting that's
upsetting to all the lefties because
they're realizing all the powers that be
all the blue check journalists you know
you'd see all these people from Daily
Beast or huffpo or whatever it might be
BuzzFeed that would have the blue check
and you'd go oh somebody wrote an
article and they have a blue check they
must be somewhat legitimate but now we
know they were buying the blue check or
they were getting it through their
organization now regular people can get
the blue check so it is democratizing uh
the value of your account right uh you
don't get unearned credit just because
you happen to work a Daily Beast or
something which is a crap Factory so who
is upset that there are more voices no
there it's not we have no evidence right
now that suddenly there's way more
threats on Twitter and there's way more
hate on Twitter go but six months ago
eight months ago four years ago I've
gotten a tremendous amount of hate on
Twitter you're not going to believe this
you can either sit there and read it or
you can press block or mute or you
cannot even open your app it's quite
extraordinary what you as a human being
can do in relationship to your little
magical advice